Bieber Tate and who and Drake I'm going
to be so bad at this huh I mean I feel
like we're not being set up for Success
here on on some of these [Music] lines
I never had you although I would be glad
to I'd probably go and tattoo your name
on my heart is that uh Bieber Bieber beibs
Bieber that might be Tade I'm going to take
gu [Music] I never had you although I would
be glad to probably go and tattoo name on my
heart I was going to say [Music] Drake I hope
I don't run out of of time could someone call
a referee uh Drake sounds like a rap song I feel
like Bieber wouldn't say that I don't know is that
Drake I hope I don't run out of time someone call
a [Music] referee really what
song is that from s okay really
[Music] jees
and I swear I care a lot just not enough let's
just say it is what it is and was what it was
I feel like that's Drake I'm going to
go tapate McCrae let's go tap McCrae
Drake and I swear I care a lot just not enough
let's just say it is what it is and was what it
was
[Music] no I was driving I thought that I saw
you and I almost crashed the sad part is if the
roles were reversed you would have drove right
past going bebbs a Bieber again I'm going to say
Drake I was driving I thought
that I saw you and I almost
crashed the sad part is if the were
reversed you would have drove right
past it's Tav cray knew it
brutal tough showing this [Music]
morning it's obvious you're pretty heard
that you're a student working weekends in
the city sounds like Drake is that Drake
I have to go Bieber should like get the
Rhythm here it's obvious you're pretty heard
that you're a student working weekends in the
city hey there you
go I have a list of all my bad habits
habits wish I didn't have it so bad is
that tap McCrae I don't recognize it
too much but I'm going to guess Tate
McCrae [Music] Bieber I have a list of all
my habits habits wish I didn't have it so
bad undercover T McCrae
fan make you shine bright like you're laying
in the snow [Music] I mean I can't be taping
cray back to back so I feel mean make you shine
bright like you're laying in the snow this doesn't
sound like bebs or Drake either [Music] though I'm
going to go Drake I'm going to go Drake uh is it
Justin make you shine bright
like you're laying in the the
snow my wife's going to be
pissed me for missing that
[Music] one if you had a twin
I'd still Choose You Drake
Drake if you had a twin I would still Choose
You [Music] bag
and when your battery gets low I'm
going be the one to charge it up
uh that's is that Drake it's
got to be Drake right is that
Drake and when your battery gets slow I'm
going to be the one to charge it [Music]
up
Bieber is that the last one
that's the last one I have
no clue yeah I don't know music at all
so I ask call a friend sir ask ask the
crowd